pakistan's prime minister the former
cricketer imran khan has been ousted
from power after losing a vote of no
confidence in parliament the supreme
court on thursday restored parliament
after khan tried to disband it to avoid
the vote khan was deserted by coalition
partners who blame him for a crumbling
economy and his failure to deliver on
his campaign promises
[Music]
islamabad residents gathered around
parliament as assembly members left
after the historic late night vote
some celebrated the ouster of prime
minister imran khan while others
protested
opposition leader shahbaz sharif is
likely to become pakistan's next prime
minister he's the brother of disgraced
former prime minister nawaz sharif
shabaz sharif who leads the pakistan
muslim league praised the no confidence
vote
allah has answered the prayers of
millions of pakistani mothers sisters
daughters elders and youth
meanwhile imran khan has accused the u.s
of conspiring to topple him over his
ties with russia and china that has
angered his supporters
has been removed through a foreign
conspiracy god willing we will fight
back to make him prime minister again we
don't want these thieves in power
those suffering under pakistan's
crumbling economy feel it was high time
for khan to go
it had to happen because conditions in
the country have become very bad
inflation has reached a peak and the
poor cannot feed their families
as pakistan woke up to a new reality
police forces were on alert
divided opinions means protests are
likely to continue until parliament
meets on monday to elect a new prime
minister
khan has claimed he's the victim of a
u.s conspiracy to topple him dw shamiel
shams gave us this analysis
he has built this narrative that the
opposition parties conspired with the us
took money from the us there was a cable
diplomatic
which no one has
validated as yet but he has been
building this anti-west uh narrative
that he wants to use in the next
election because now the entire
government would hold the fresh
elections after some electoral reforms
so he will try to whip up this anti-west
anti-us sentiment which is arrived in
pakistan for various reasons so that's
what he's going to do and he'll try to
create problems for the new government
the new entire prime minister
but it won't be that easy for him
he won't recognize the government and he
has a lot of followers it won't khan has
claimed he's the victim of a u.s
conspiracy to topple him dw shamiel
shams gave us this analysis
he has built this narrative that the
opposition parties conspired with the us
took money from the u.s there was a
cable diplomatic uh which no one has
validated as yet but he has been
building this anti-west
narrative that he wants to use in the
next election because now the entire
government would hold the fresh
elections after some electoral reforms
so he will try to whip up this anti-west
anti-us sentiment which is arrived in
pakistan for various reasons so that's
what he's going to do and he'll try to
create problems for the new government
the new interim prime minister
but it won't be that easy for him
he won't recognize the government and he
has a lot of followers it won't be an
easy ride from here